مشاهدينا الكرام هو صوت الطائرات المسيره
التي ما زالت تجوب سماء قطاع غزه ولكن
بالتزامن مع ذلك والتي ينسب اليها كما
قلنا قصف مجموعه من الشقق او المنازل
الفلسطينيه بالتزامن مع ذلك هنالك دخول
لسلاح الجو والطائرات الحربيه وقصف نحن
على راس الساعه الان الطائرات الحربيه
مشاهدين الكرام تقصف اهدافا في مدينه غزه
وسلسله من الغارات العنيفه على انحاء
متفرقه في قطاع غزه ننتقل الى جيفارا
البديري جيفارا انت في متابعه الاعلام
الاسرائيلي وما ينشر الان عن الشخصيات
التي سماها
والقاده الذين تم اغتيالهم منهم طارق عز
الدين وكذلك الاسماء التي وصفها
الجانب الجيش الاسرائيلي وصفها بانها امين
سر
الكتائب المجلس العسكري لسرايا القدس
وكذلك
يعني نشر معلومات تفصيليه
المختصه
بالمسؤول عن العمليات التي تجري في الضفه
الغربيه من قطاع غزه جيفارا انت في
الاستماع ما هي التفاصيل المعلنه
اسرائيليا عن القاده الذين تم اغتياله
[موسيقى]
اسرائيل وخطط لاطلاق صواريخ نحو اسرائيل
في المستقبل القريب ويبلغ من العمر 44
عاما وهو من سكان مدينه غزه اما الشخصيه
الثانيه وهو المستهدف في هذه العمليه هو
طارق عز الدين يتهمه الاحتلال بانه
المسؤول عن توجيه
العمليات في داخل الضفه الغربيه انطلاقا
من قطاع غزه اي ان الاحتلال يتهم طارق عز
الدين بالمسؤوليه عن العمليات التي ينفذها
تنفذها سرايا القدس الجناح المسلح لحركه
الجهاد الاسلامي في الضفه الغربيه وانه
ايضا
في الاونه الاخيره قام بالتخطيط وتوجيه
عمليات ضد سكان دوله اسرائيل وهو من
مواليد قريه عرابه قضاء
وبالتالي هو من الضفه الغربيه وهو من
محرري صفقه شليط اما الشخصيه فهو القيادي
نعم نعم مبعد الى قطاع غزه هذا حسب وصف
بيان جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي محمد اما
الشخصيه الثالثه فهو القيادي جهاد غنام
الذي حسب وصف البيان ايضا انه يشغل منصب
امين سر المجلس العسكري في الجهاز
الاسلامي وهو من سكان رفح ويبلغ من العمر
62 عاما ويعتبر من ابرز قيادات الجهاد
وشغل عده مناصب رفيعه وهو مسؤول حسب ادعاء
الاحتلال عن تنسيق ونقل الاموال واسلحه
بين الجهاد الاسلامي وحركه حماس وتورط في
توجيه نشاطات للجهاد من قطاع غزه وايضا في
الضفه
غربيه بالطبع هذه العمليه المتواصله الذي
اكد الجيش الاسرائيلي انها
تستمر اسمائها بعمليه السهم الواقي وحسب
صوره نشرها الجيش الاسرائيلي قال فيها ان
انه عندما يخطئ ارهاب الجهاد الاسلامي
التقدير ويدخل في دوامه اخطاء تاتي السهام
وتنهار اعمال هذا حسب صوره نشرها الجيش
الاسرائيلي جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي قبل
قليل فقط لنعود ونذكر بكل مجمل الاحداث في
تقريبا في الساعه الواحده وخمسين دقيقه
بتوقيت فلسطين اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي لانه
بدا بتنفيذ غارات واهداف ضد قطاع غزه وانه
يستهدف قيادات في حركه الجهاد الاسلامي
تحديدا وانه يستهدف مواقع ومقر قياديه
للجهاد وانه كان وبعد لحظات قام بالاعلان
بانه قام بقتل عدد من قيادات كبار في
القطاع وايضا فقط هنا للاشاره السريعه
نعم تفضل يا جيفارا اكملي
يعني التصريحات السريعه وسائل الاعلام
اسرائيليه تؤكد ان نتنياهو كان قد اعلن
واعد واشرف على الخطط لهذه العمليه
العسكريه التي يمكن الان بالفعل ان ترقى
الى حرب بين
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وفصائل المقاومه
في قطاع غزه باستهداف هذا العدد الهائل من
قيادات سرايا القدس في الجهاد الاسلامي
اذا